first question I feel like my girlfriend  is cheating on me and messaging other  guys on Instagram does anyone know how I  can get into her account since she  doesn't give me her phone and changes  the topic every time is your girlfriend  cheating on you  probably yes you probably is I mean  chances are pretty good look it's not  her responsibility to hand her phone  over to you in the first place she's not  your child but if you're noticing some  weird secrecy around phones and  messaging and that sort of thing 99  chance that it's exactly what you think  it is I hate to tell you  so this is one where I would say  probably best to break up  probably heading that way anyway  regardless of the cheating or the  potential cheating so I would I would  simply break up